there has only been news coverage of a
couple of mass shootings in 2018
including one in Kentucky after which
the Canadian Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau sent a message of support to the
victims but President Trump was weirdly
silent about it but even though we're
not even one month into 2018 the numbers
are already horrifying I started
thinking about this again after that
call we got last week last week during
live calls if you missed it a pro-gun
liberal called in and we talked a little
bit and it made me reinvigorated for
exploring what the gun death statistics
were for 2018 so far and it's really
really bad we've got for you from gun
violence archive.org as of today January
29 2018 there have been over 4,100
shootings in the United States so far in
2018 remember were not even a month in
there have been over 1,100 deaths from
shootings in the US and over 2000
injuries almost fifty kids aged 11 or
under have been killed by guns in just
January 215 teens aged 12 to 17 killed
in the United States by guns just so far
21 mass shootings and just a hundred and
twenty-one defensive uses of guns and a
defensive use does not even necessarily
mean that the gun was actually fired nor
that it was actually necessary to use a
gun and of course unintentional
shootings I call them
negligent discharges 145 they're just in
the last 24 hours
we've had shootings everywhere from here
in the Boston area to Tucson Arizona to
Charlotte North Carolina to Houston
Texas as well as in small towns like
Diver Ville Mississippi and McKees Rocks
Pennsylvania there were four mass
shootings just over the weekend there
was one in Bowling Green Kentucky no
that's not the bowling-green massacre
that Kellyanne Conway was talking about
once this is an actual mass shooting
that took place in Bowling Green
Kentucky mass shooting in Los Angeles
California we had a mass shooting over
the weekend in Mel Croft Pennsylvania
and also one in Indianapolis Indiana and
to really deal with this issue there
needs to be a
all encompassing multifaceted solution
and there's a couple different problems
here right number one is an issue of
tactics the pro-gun right is correct
that if you just limit the types of guns
or ammo alone you're not going to fix
the broader gun violence problem in the
United States if you are on the pro-gun
right you're wrong if you say we should
only be looking at mental health it's
not just a mental health issue the left
likewise is wrong if they believe that
background checks and banning assault
weapons is the panacea to solve this
problem this is about availability of
guns lack of background checks and
required training it is about mental
health but most importantly and sort of
more broadly this is about the toxic
relationship that exists in the United
States between too many Americans and
their guns where people see firearms as
tools to solve problems this means tools
to solve interpersonal problems tools to
solve political disagreements and
disputes that's the part that really has
to be changed and I don't actually know
how you change that but in the meantime
there are other things we can do last
thing I want to say about this there's a
growing movement on the Internet mostly
that like to say that they are about
principles and ideas and they say we
don't want to get mixed up so much in
the day-to-day politics and policy
because the principles are what matter
if you can't identify your principles
then you're gonna be completely clueless
about what are the actual policies you
should support or oppose the problem
with that and I've been working on this
a little bit I've been talking to one of
our longtime viewers and friends a Greg
Stephens about this and and some other
people the problem is that unless you
realize that no set of principles will
be all encompassing you will falsely be
lulled into this idea that if you can
just come up with some hard and fast
principles you never will actually have
to do the work of thinking through
complicated situations and that relates
to guns how it relates to guns because
if you take the position that we have a
Second Amendment and we do not need nor
does the Constitution
for common-sense gun safety regulation
you don't actually have to do the tough
work of figuring out what is
specifically going on in the US when it
comes to guns how would a combination of
mental health and restrictions on
firearms and training and background
checks how would all of those things
together impact the problem that we have
you can just do the easy thing which is
cite a principle based on a multi
hundred-year-old document and your
particular interpretation of that Second
Amendment and say listen I'm a
constitutionalist and this is what the
Constitution says that's really what
matters and that is it is a dangerous
movement that we can apply to a lot of
places this is not me going on some kind
of like postmodern rant where nothing
has meaning and everything is equally
valid and there's no objective reality
that's not what I'm saying what I am
Telling You is that any movement that's
looking for sort of universal principles
that will apply in every situation and
sort of excuse you from having to
actually look at the numbers I presented
to you here about gun violence and say
we've actually got to go beyond just our
principles and ideals and figure out
solutions it is actually a cop out and I
would encourage a lot of the people that
are being bamboozled by this internet
movement of let's just list our
principles and debate ideas you're
falling for something that will not
actually get get us to real-world
solutions and that's a real problem
discuss this with us on our reddit
discussion forum at david pakman.com
slash our IDI di t today's program is
sponsored in part by movement you guys
have heard me talk about movement you
know about those two college dropouts
that started their watch company I'm
wearing one of their watches today
everywhere I go people love the watch
they ask me where did I get the watch
and it's crazy how fast the company has
grown they've now sold almost two
million watches in over a hundred and
sixty countries and they're continuing
to revolutionize fashion in the belief
that style shouldn't break the bank
anyone who knows me knows I agree with
that I don't believe that style should
break the bank and they've doubled their
number of watch styles and are now also
offering high quality sunglasses
two pairs of which I have as well as
women's bracelets and if you thought
that gift-giving ended in December
Valentine's Day is coming up and our
friends at movement have put together
the perfect interactive gift guide to
make Valentines shopping painless
whether you're shopping for him or her
find everything from watches to
fashion-forward bracelets and sunglasses
and movements limited-edition gift box
all curated by movements in-house
stylists with their trendiest pieces
that your special someone will love get
15% off today with free shipping and
free returns by going to M V M t.com
forward slash Pakman join the movement
go to M V M t.com /pa k ma n